this right here is the most unique
functional and creative set of
projectors I've ever seen the N1 series
Sent to us from our sponsor jmgo and the
reason they're so special is because
they're actually gimbal projectors that
are packed with high-end specs with
triple laser projection and more now if
you don't know what I mean when I say
gimbal I mean this the entire projector
is on a unique stand with a hinge that
pans and tilts like a gimbal solving the
biggest challenge that portable
projectors usually have which is quick
and easy setup because with other
projectors you have to find a stand or
even stack multiple things on top of
each other to raise the height of the
projector but with the JM go N1 N1 Pro
and N1 Ultra gimbal projectors you can
set it down on basically anything
regardless of how high it is and simply
adjust the angle to the desired spot on
the wall and the auto gimbal adjustment
feature will instantly fix the Keystone
angle for a per perfectly straight image
as well as instantly auto focus which
works by using the set of lasers in the
front and now the second challenge that
jmgo has solved is picture quality and
they did it by integrating an RGB triple
laser light source which is the most
advanced projection technology out today
so let's get into picture quality
starting with the N1 Ultra which is
their highest end model and let me tell
you now it is very impressive the
unboxing experience was a breeze because
of their awesome easy to carry case made
out of dense foam so you can throw it
into your trunk while traveling or going
camping without worrying about it
getting damaged so I did just that I
took it to our family's campgrounds and
the setup was a breeze with just a
single power cable that goes into the
stand on the right side that's it the
projector does come with a couple of
HDMI 2.1 ports one supporting e-arc
which is great if you don't have an
internet connection but since we had
Wi-Fi fight I was able to connect
quickly to the Android TV 11 OS which is
basically like a fully featured Smart TV
built into the projector with almost all
of the streaming apps out there we
turned on some cartoons for the kids and
wow the image was absolutely incredible
with 4K UHD resolution which was very
sharp and 2200 cvia lumens of brightness
that was so bright it basically lit up
the surrounding area from the
reflections but don't worry you can
manually adjust the brightness in the
settings or just turn on the smart
brightness feature which will
automatically adapt it to the
environment but that crazy high level of
brightness was awesome because it lets
you watch movies without having to
completely black out all the lights to
get a great looking image even being
able to watch in the daytime because of
the triple laser light source the
quality and contrast ratio was a
beautiful 1600 to 1 with HDR 10 support
and 10 bit color depth and the lamp
should last over 30 000 hours which is
pretty insane now one thing that really
impressed me was that the speakers were
so loud we had to turn them down in
order to keep the piece with dual 10
watt speakers and bass that goes down to
45 Hertz which is very impressive and
helps it get its Dolby audio
certification
and I was also glad to see that all
three of the and one series of
projectors from jmgo support Wi-Fi 6 and
Bluetooth 5.0 for a reliable connection
to the internet and the Bluetooth remote
that works very well and they all come
with the headphone jack and a USB a port
as well the whole gimbal aspect was
really cool with 135 degrees of vertical
adjustment so you can spin it side to
side and the digital Zoom controls made
it really easy to adjust the image to
the perfect size and they even sell
unique ceiling and wall mounts as well
as these clean looking stance but man
this projector seriously looks amazing
with its high contrast ratio and deep
blacks that are only possible with the
triple Laser Technology and if you get a
bit closer you can see just how
incredibly good the 4K quality really is
and that 4K resolution is so important
important because it allows you to make
the screen huge like up to 150 inches
while still having great quality and
brightness thanks to those 2200 lumens
and the best part is that it's actually
quite affordable compared to the
competition at this high-end range
starting at twenty three hundred dollars
but currently on sale during Amazon's
Prime Day July 11th and 12th for 1724
using the promo code and Link in the
description below now for the rest of
the N1 series we have the N1 Pro and the
N1 but first I want to mention that the
N1 series is highly recommended by
Academy Awards winning filmmakers like
Adam Leipzig Rachel Morrison and Ed
Lucas in the professional field now
getting back to the N1 Pro is basically
identical to the N1 Ultra except for
three differences it comes with a lower
1700 retail price currently just a
thousand a 159 bucks for Amazon's Prime
day using the the coupon code in the
description and that's because it
features 1080p resolution and 1500 cvia
lumens so it's basically the option for
those looking to save some money while
still getting a great experience in all
of the other features the 1500 lumens
definitely isn't as bright as the N1
Ultra but it's more than good enough for
most people especially if you're
watching movies in the evening or
nighttime since it's still brighter than
a lot of the competition and as you can
see even in daytime it's still very
bright now while the N1 Ultra offers the
ultimate viewing experience with a 4K
resolution the N1 Pro provides 1080p
resolution which can meet most users
needs as it also handles 4K signals with
down scaling to 1080p so it still looks
really good it still packs the same
great quality speakers as well as all
the other features and specs so you're
still getting a killer projector for a
great price being basically 600 less
expensive than the N1 Ultra but still
bright enough for watching movies during
daytime with blinds half lifted so it's
perfect for those who don't want to go
all out and get the best of the best and
now let's get into the N1 model which is
way different than the others with a
clean white and gray finish this model
is focused on portability being a lot
smaller than the other two and less than
half the weight making it the best
option if you want to take it with you
on the road or camping is still packs a
bunch of the technology including the
triple laser light source with HDR 10
quality with 1600 to 1 contrast ratio
and 10 bit color depth but it's toned
down in terms of the specs in order to
get the price down to just 999 dollars
or 749 for Prime day it still gets full
1080p HD quality which is great but the
brightness gets toned down to 800 cvia
lumens so it's not as bright as the
other two but I tested it at night while
camping and it was quite bright in the
dark and it was completely fine for
everybody and because of the triple
laser tech the image is actually easier
to see compared to other basic
projectors and still offering a great
experience with really really great
colors it still came with dual speakers
but they're both 5 Watts instead of 10
so they're not as loud but still offers
the same 45 Hertz base now the base of
the N1 is designed as a handle so you
can easily lift it up with one hand and
take it somewhere which further
contributes to the portability of the N1
and it's really lightweight and easy to
move around and thankfully it still
features Wi-Fi 6 and Bluetooth 5.0 as
well as a single HDMI 2.1 port with
e-arc so I'm glad they didn't skimp on
the connection specs it also comes with
the same mediatek mt9629 chip so it
doesn't have any drawbacks in terms of
the performance of the UI so it's still
very smooth and reliable now if you're
trying to figure out which one of these
to buy the N1 Ultra is the premium model
of the lineup with an emphasis on the
best possible picture quality with 4K
resolution and 2200 cvia lumens of
brightness which is bright enough for
daytime viewing so at twenty three
hundred dollars it's a really
competitive option for those seeking the
best possible picture quality and need
the projector's position to be flexible
at the same time now at 16.99 the N1 Pro
offers native 1080p resolution and 1500
cvia lumens with the same laser tech and
gimbal designed as the N1 Ultra so it's
the most cost effective option in the N1
series and finally the N1 focuses on
portability being much smaller and
lighter than the other two so you can
easily take it with you anywhere like I
did for camping and gathering with
friends and at 999 dollars it still
offers Next Level portability as well as
decent 1080p picture quality with 800
cvia lumens so with all that said I
think jmgo made an absolutely killer
lineup for projectors with their N1
series with leading triple color laser
technology that promises a premium
viewing experience and Innovative gimbal
design that takes portability and
adjustability to the next level and as a
user oriented company jamgo says they
aspire to revolutionize users viewing
experiences with the N1 series and I
love how they tune the features and
specs to match every free price range
from under a thousand bucks all the way
up to the N1 Ultra which you can now get
with prime day for 17.24 which is
honestly a killer deal for how insanely
high quality the image is especially
with that 2200 lumens of brightness that
lets you watch movies in the daytime or
with the lights on so hopefully you
enjoyed this review and if you did go
ahead and use
one codes down below to snatch one of
these up for Prime day before the price
goes back up to retail pricing thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
thank you